Secret number three to writing viral
hooks. You want to add a constraint to
make your headline significantly more
interesting. So, check this out. I take
this headline, very kind of generic
mainstream headline, how to make $1,000
per day. You've probably seen that
headline many, many a times. Now, we're
going to make it significantly more
interesting by adding a constraint. How
to make $1,000 per day with no skill.
That's a constraint that you can put in
parenthesis at the end of your headline
to make it more interesting to your
ideal target audience. This would be
targeting beginners, right? How to make
$1,000 per day with no skill. Or you
might be targeting like work atome moms
who don't have a lot of time in the day.
You might say something like how to make
$1,000 per day in just 43 minutes a day.
Targeting busy people, something that
resonates with them. Another way you
might say this is how to make $1,000 per
day without the internet. Do you see how
these constraints make the headline
infinitely more interesting? That will
be more clicks and sales and attention.